hello everybody and welcome to today's
licensing meeting a bit of housekeeping
fire alarm procedures if the fire alarm
is activated please take the stairs down
to the reception area and out of the
building to the Green in Hawley Square
which is the assembly point please do
not use the lifts officers will assist
you in advice when it's deemed safe to
return to the council offices
um filming and I would avoid that if
filming takes place anyone in attendance
in the public areas may have their image
captured I heard anyone filming
proceedings to avoid filming members of
the public particularly if there are
only children present does anyone intend
filming
over here
um okay
um mobile phones but everyone present
please ensure that their mobile phones
are turned silent and that they are not
used to make or receive phone calls in
this room whilst the meeting is in
progress
agenda item one apologies for absence
um counselor Dennis sent his apologies
are there any other apologies for
absence no
um Declarations of Interest are there
any Declarations of Interest
you like got your hands up
no
um okay minutes of the last meeting
agenda three
please can I remember proposed and
second that the minutes the licensing
board meeting held on the 4th of October
2022 be approved as a correct record and
can I have a proposer councilor scoby
and Kevin seconder councilor Saunders
thank you do members agree
agree
um exclusion of the press and public
please can I have a member prize in
second that the public and press be
excluded for the meeting for the agenda
item five as it contains exempt
information as defined in paragraph
seven and part one of schedule 12a of
the Local Government Act 1972
um can I have a proposal and a second uh
counselor Schwab
and councilor Wing second and do members
agree okay thank you
okay clear the chamber
and it can never have to come through as
well thank you yeah